[Music]
hello I'm Alexa Mencia creative director
on Assassin's Creed unity today were
proud to be showcasing a small slice of
our single-player campaign
[Music]
[Music]
what's our plan
our plan you're not an apprentice
anymore boy it's a study your
surroundings devise your own plan I'm
not here to hold your hand
[Music]
no targets and reach out of the way move
where they always do [ __ ] oh if you
can't find a weakness to exploit make
one you secure the cathedral premise you
good tell severe I'll meet you inside
Ginnie's everywhere to get back here
with my cane and if all other plans fail
when I sacrifice yourself for the cost
or life for his before I'll tire that
was the Levantine approach you mean a
dagger in broad daylight as I'm cut down
where I stand
sends a powerful message I'll do it my
way
whatever you think best assassin
this is one of our nose-first
assignments as an assassin and he must
kill she'll give a and survive a
thuggish templar with strong economic
connections all of the games main
assassinations now take place in a new
type of mission called black boxes these
missions are designed to let players
craft their unique experience by
allowing them to approach the mission
any way they see fit in other words we
give you an objective and that's it no
linear paths or narrow level design are
forced upon you you make your own
opportunities additionally we provide
you with mod missions which are optional
objectives within the mission which
actually change how it unfolds
more on that later
let's find another way of infiltrating
look for them this is where the mod
missions come into play we first saw
hint of it in the interest in nomadic
regarding a man called Duchesneau let's
look for him in this crowd gathered in
front of look for them we could try to
kill him now but there are too many
guards around it seems that he's meeting
a priest
we might get useful information by
following him the new parkour experience
gives you improved freedom of movement
and allows you to select different paths
on the flight
we really wanted to improve the players
stealth experience immunity and have
consequently integrated a brand new
stealth mode let's use the silent
approach to reach in stealth mode could
be activated
anywhere and provides you with the
silence and agility of a predator how
long will it be before the
revolutionaries descend on Mother Church
very well I'll make arrangements with
Monsieur severe and see that the
confession is alive my employer prefers
to discuss business away we got the info
we needed let's use a smoke bomb to
blind and assassinate Duchesneau by the
time the smoke dissipates I'll be long
gone
lifts are still present in ACU and you
can use them for quick access to harder
to reach places this door is locked I
could try to pick the lock but I don't
yet have a lockpick skill let's follow
our current lead and continue the mod
mission objective climbing look for them
you can see the level of detail and
realism we've attained in the recreation
of this iconic landmark from the top you
can see the city of Paris spread out as
far as the eye can see Paris is the
biggest densest and most immersive city
we've ever created
[Music]
[Music]
senseless
here are the thugs we saw in the
cinematic they stole the keys to not
throw them from the priestess by
stealing them back I could enter the
Cathedral much more easily let's avoid
getting into a fight by using a stealth
approach why not right the Archbishop's
wine cellar
[Music]
now that we have the keys we can finally
enter the kadam note that this is but
one of 10 possible entrances
[Music]
[Music]
notice the attention to detail we've put
into recreating the massive Nevada
interior all iconic landmarks and ACU
have fully modeled custom interiors all
filled with various activities
[Music]
we still have the iconic leap of faith
just look for haystack the red dot on
the mini-map in the bottom-left of the
screen
[Music]
[Music]
damn it now
Savannah entered the confessional while
he was supposed to meet you Shannon but
as we've taken care of the [ __ ] know in
the first mob mission we can take this
place in the confessional and kill Siva
without alarming the guards everything
is in place finally some recent dizzy
what's our cut 30% good good this is our
moment my friend petty nobles are ripe
enough fruits but the church has been
leeching off the people for centuries
crack there are faults the Grand Master
cannot fail to recognize our work as you
say good wait here you see there but not
disturb mr. latouche I'm here to see the
king of beggar's you're right miss here
we have to escape not for them but given
the number of guards
using the main entrance would be
suicidal
[Music]
- one at very taught them too
the Paris of ACU is a multi-layered city
with multiple underground passages you
can enter a building from the top and
get up through the underground the
possibilities are endless
Oh
[Music]
this demo was but a glimpse of our rich
open world stay tuned for more and thank
you for watching
[Music]
make history Assassin's Creed unity
pre-order now for two bonus offers the
PIA team spindle in game get a chance to
win prizes every Friday and the
explosive chemical revolution mission
pre-order now available October 28th